hey Keith and both were Keith what's
going on buddy hey good morning morning
buddy
so one of the things I love most about
Jimmie is this overuse of the worksheet
he hates a lot of stuff yes all the
things on air good good what is it what
is it what is the list sound like Keith
okay so a bird that can fly but still
died by the way if one of them is a bird
they deserve it why if one bird oh
because they should if they could just
fly over your bird and you can't get
away from a fire you really are a piece
of [ __ ] I see no okay
I guess again yeah let's hate oh boy I
guess in photos yeah I saw someone say
cheese recently in a photo we remember
where I was a bunch of us taking one say
cheese and cheese like a grown up
[ __ ] shut up not me talk not see I
hate not see talk other sick you hear
about the [ __ ] Nazis can everybody
just stop with the Nazis why there's no
Nazi threat in the US there's just not
well it's their diction everybody knows
their dicks
that's [ __ ] Nazi paranoia shut up but
why do they need our help it's a country
and it's on fire handle it every year
this [ __ ] wildfires in California
it's true people are like I put a dirt
barrier around the entire city some
[ __ ] [ __ ] pigeon picks up a
[ __ ] cigarette butt and drops it and
the next thing you know you got a
[ __ ] move to San Francisco yeah but
you put a dirt but dirt around Los
Angeles I'm sick of it okay he will say
no Pete I hate it that was from a photo
that we were looking at the guy had a
wicker Lapidus I hate the lamp I hate
the wicker lamp he's gonna have an apple
and some coffee and a wicker lamp and
his beige seat what a [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
nation that is a granny smith apple and
a [ __ ] coffee the word potty potty
yes potting up something right yeah I
hate the word potting I [ __ ] hate
these people who think that they're
really being these [ __ ] like grounded
New Yorkers or whatever by not like yeah
I don't use this cell yeah well aren't
you an [ __ ] right yep rest in power
that's what we say on this no we don't
what no we don't listen you're not
resting in power you're [ __ ] dead
rest in power hey that's a statement
yeah did you ever see that on Twitter I
hate it tirade yesterday against Meryl
Streep when he yaps about Meryl Streep
first ones sick of her everybody loved
her and what big little lies yeah she's
Meryl Streep doesn't he ever get
exhausting all the jewelry like I hate
wearing jewelry I say my best friend is
the lady broadcasting you don't like my
shirt why it's just off you have to know
why I hate that Bob is top and it just
disturbs me so that's all just this
calendar year that's all just January
16th so in like yeah I guess this is
we've done it eight shows so fun 2020 so
in eight shows that's the list of things
Jim hey Thank You Keith you're not wrong
some of those do sound unreasonable
[Laughter]
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]